who reminds you of yourself the most
right now in the league
um
in my prime
i was i mean my prime kawhi
you know um
playing at my best
um
probably kawhi
said he he'd lock you up
and he um to play offense
you know what i'm saying and also he's
like he's not going to always get 40 and
40 and 40. right he gonna get 28 34
27 but
be the best player on the floor 100 you
know what i'm saying which is like
i could i could relate i never had 40 in
the nba
you know but i was the go-to guy
multiple teams yeah you were yeah but i
was spending so much time on defense so
kawhi is somebody who i really like
do you think um
you know in in the the league has
changed so much with three-point
shooting obviously the warriors kind of
revolutionized the way kids are growing
up watching basketball
um
do you think defense has kind of gotten
lost in in the in the uh
in the kind of you know when we were
kids when i was watching you or watching
you know the era before you when you
were watching basketball defense was a
very important part of the game yeah
nowadays it feels like it's so secondary
that like the league like we'll see some
of these scores especially this year the
scores are crazy yeah yeah yeah yeah
like putting up 130 is nothing now where
like back in the day if someone put up
130 you'd be like what the [ __ ] well
they took the hands off right i can't
touch as much um so you don't really
have a reason to love defense
you know what i'm saying right now
like when i was growing up it was a
reason why i was doing my defensive
slides in the summertime while i was
gonna be while i was a pro because i had
to stop someone and it was aggressive
and
you know our
last game against detroit it was uh 70
73 to 69. crazy to go to the finals
that's so crazy you know that's a
college score
to go to the finals that is so crazy
most of the games i played in in the
playoffs
were all low scores
mostly that's real the the lakers would
be the boston 83 83.79 wow